a couple Logistics first the project
poster session is on Wednesday next week
I will be posting details on Ed very
soon it'll actually be broken up because
we have so many students in the class
who want to be broken up into two
different sessions and you'll be
assigned to one of the two sessions and
so there'll be a bunch of details on
that uh coming soon on Ed
the final project report is due in two
weeks on Monday
um and then a couple other logistical
items from the high resolution feedback
uh first uh the high resolution feedback
from before Thanksgiving break uh was
about kind of the timing of homework
three and homework four and so we we
visit that timing for the next offering
um
and then another thing that has come up
a couple of different times was asking
for solutions to the to the homeworks
and there is we've had a lot of
discussion around it and it's something
that I think is always
um
a little bit tricky to do uh the in
particular the thing that's tricky is
that uh
we reuse the assignments um
over time over different quarters and we
do that so that we can have a very high
standard and a high quality of the
assignments but it also means that if we
post the solutions uh this quarter then
it could be that those Solutions stay
floating around and other students use
those solutions for future quarters and
we have seen in the past cases where
students have actually posted their own
Solutions online and students have
copied those Solutions and so we don't
want to incentivize that sort of
cheating and so as a result we don't
post Solutions which is somewhat
unfortunate but if you have questions
about mistakes on the homework either
about your grade or anything really feel
free to make a post on Ed or come to
office hours and we're really happy to
walk through
walk through the solution to the
homework and hopefully that's just as
good as having access to the solution
so my plan for today is really to talk
about uh the kind of most recent uh
Trends in research that I find really
exciting uh and so this is I think a
pretty fun lecture because
um yeah I basically will talk about some
of the things that I think are really
cool that are on the edge of research
um this will be including Better
Learning for adapting to distribution
shift including adapting with unlabeled
examples and adopting with
um kind of local descriptions of an edit
that you want to make to a model
uh and then I'll also be talking about
how we can meddle in things that are
more General than
um some of the things that we've seen in
the past and this includes trying to
meddler in a generic Optimizer that can
be used for any different problem as
well as trying to meddler and symmetries
in neural network architectures
and at the very end I'll talk a bit
about what I think are some outstanding
open problems and challenges in the
field and uh and yeah
um how how we might start to to move
towards addressing those challenges
cool um so let's first talk a little bit
about adapting to distribution shift and
the first is why this actually matters
at all uh I think distribution shift is
a really fascinating problem and I think
that it's really an important problem
because of um kind of the nature of
reality so the current Paradigm in
machine learning research is to take a
data set then train a model on that data
set and then evaluate that model on
um on on some held out data or something
like that
uh but in reality things are constantly
changing in the world and so we see
stocks or supply and demand or you kind
of deploy your system in a different
part of the world and as a result the
data that the system is often deployed
on is actually different from the data
that it saw during training
and I think we need algorithms that can
handle the fact that the world is
changing rather than just being deployed
as a static system
and I also think that metal learning is
actually possibly a very useful tool for
trying to address this challenge because
meta learning can train systems that can
adapt very quickly and so we'll see that
a little bit in some of the upcoming
slides
now if this is kind of a current
um reality that's that's faced you might
ask well how does what does industry do
so when actually people use machine
learning and practice uh how do they
cope with the fact that the world is
constantly changing
um and you could ask um who works on
machine learning systems and she says
that machine Learning Systems degrade
quickly over time because of concept
drift
uh when they're in production and uh for
online machine Learning Systems
typically you just want to update them
as fast as humanly possible in order to
kind of address the fact that they
degrade quickly because of content drift
um and so I think this is actually uh
an interesting uh thing to know about
because it means that the way that we
typically
um develop machine Learning Systems is
under this kind of train test Paradigm
and actually the way they're being used
in practice is this sort of continual
training setting which is a bit
different from the way that they were
originally intended and so maybe that
means if we want to build better machine
learning systems and
um
and to kind of actually do research
that's relevant to the real world maybe
we should take into account the fact
that they need to be updated constantly
over time
cool um and so
fine-tuning is a really reliable and
performant approach for trying to update
models quickly over time
but it also has some limitations so
first it requires you to collect labeled
data from the new part of the data
distribution and this can be expensive
it can take time it may not be available
I can also be computationally expensive
and especially as you're trying to train
larger and larger models
the amount of compute you'll need to
fine-tune that model will at some point
become somewhat impractical
and in general it's a fairly blunt tool
and if you only want to make a very
small change to your model because you
notice an error or notice like one small
thing that changed uh fine-tuning is
isn't necessarily the best tool to make
a very precise and small change to your
model
and so yeah what I'll talk about next is
how we can might be able to leverage
better learning to actually address some
of these weaknesses of fine-tuning
cool
um so first we'll focus on domain shift
and this is something a kind of
distribution shift that we saw in the
domain adaptation and domain
generalization lectures and then after
we talk about domain shift we'll talk
about a more General kind of
distribution shift that's called concept
shift
um and so to recap uh in domain shift
you have some sort of categorical domain
variable
and this could correspond to different
users to different locations different
times of day
um and oftentimes this sort of domain
information can be derived from metadata
that already exists in your training
data set
and then what domain shift looks like is
you assume that your training data is
from this distribution right here and
your test data is from the same
distribution but where the only thing
that has changed is the distribution of
this underlying domain variable
oh and this kind of distribution shift
is fairly General
um and this is the kind of the shift
that we'll look at in this first part uh
but there are also some things that it
cannot capture
now one approach I guess so we saw some
approaches for handling domain shift in
um in my lecture on domain outpatient in
Hawaii's lecture on domain
generalization and one approach that we
didn't really talk too much about is
called distributionally robust
optimization
and the way that this approach works is
you try to form some adversarial
distribution over your domain variable
and then optimize for the worst case
so in particular you can formulate kind
of a adversarial optimization where you
are trying to find a model that does
well under the worst case distribution
over domains
and
if you have a categorical domain
variable this is actually fairly simple
to evaluate you simply pick the domain
that the model is doing the worst on in
your trading data set and then optimize
for the performance on that domain
and then iterate that process
um and this sort of adversarial
optimization can enable robustness to uh
to different domains it can also be less
pessimistic than adversarial responses
which is another kind of robustness that
you might have heard about
uh but it can often sacrifice the
average performance or the empirical
performance because it's actually quite
pessimistic about the data that it will
be seeing or the domain that it will be
seeing at test time
and so what we're going to try to do is
actually kind of formulate uh an
alternative Paradigm that is a little
bit less pessimistic but still allows us
to be kind of Fairly robust and the way
that we're going to be doing that is
instead of optimizing for the worst case
domain we're going to try to actually
optimize for domain performance after
having adopted a small amount to each
given domain
and so specifically what I mean by that
is
we're going to assume that we have
unlabeled data from the test domain
this could be the unlabeled data from a
new user from a new time of day or a new
place
and so if you want to for example
recognize handwriting
this is from the Federated extended
Eminence data set this is all from one
user you might have this batch of
unlabeled data from that one user
and then your goal is to take this
unlabeled data adapt your model to that
user and then infer the labels
for uh for all the examples in that
batch
and so this is going to be different
from from other approaches in a few
different ways first unlike fine-tuning
this only needs unlabeled data in order
to adopt the model rather than labeled
data
second unlike things like domain
generalization and domain adaptation
we're not going to be assuming access to
this unlabeled data during training time
we're actually just going to adapt the
model on the fly at test time
um the really the main assumption that
this is I guess the main two assumptions
that's going to be making is that first
that you have domain labels in your
training data set and second at test
time you have a batch of test inputs
from the same group or from the same
domain available at once rather than
just having a single example
this is a little bit different from the
standard machine learning setting where
you just assume that you have
um just one input at a time at test time
so this is the problem setting
um and we kind of refer to this problem
setting as adaptive risk minimization in
the sense that you are
instead of just evaluating risk directly
on the examples that you're given you
actually have an opportunity to adapt
with a small amount of examples
and then there's a question of actually
how to optimize for this and how to
actually develop a method that can allow
you to adapt with just unlabeled data
from a new part of the distribution
and so to do this we could actually
train a model for a few shot adaptation
to the different domains in the training
data set and this will just use like
basically the same metal learning
algorithms that you saw in the earlier
parts of the course
um the key thing that's different though
is
instead of doing few shot labeled
adaptation
we're only given unlabeled data and so
we want to be able to adapt with these
unlabeled examples rather than a few
labeled examples
and so there's a few different ways that
you can do this
one is you could use the mammal
algorithm but because you can't compute
the like a standard cross-entropy loss
function
you can metal learn a loss function
and use better learn that loss function
such that when you adapt with that loss
function on the unlabeled data you do
well on each of the domains in the
training set
and so what this looks like is you are
going to be meta learning both the
initial parameters as well as the
parameters of some loss function also
represented by a neural network you
in the Inner Loop use that loss function
to update the network from the initial
parameters to get a new network and then
optimize this whole thing
end to end such that you get good
performance on each of the training
domains
um so that's one way to adapt with
unlabeled data alternatively you could
also use a black box approach and simply
basically pass in all of the unlabeled
examples into a neural network that
produces some context and use that
context to make predictions for your
examples and this sort of Black Box
approach is actually quite
straightforward because the the only
thing you need to do the only thing you
need to do to modify a black box
approach to work without labels is to
just remove the labels when you pass the
data as input
um there's a few different architectures
that you could use for this sort of uh
kind of block box approach one is the
architecture that's shown here where you
just kind of predict those contexts and
pass that into the network
alternatively this context
um could actually be computed in a
different way one really simple way to
compute this context would just have the
context correspond about storm
statistics
and this would mean that you are
um
you're basically passing all of your
examples in as a batch and instead of
using uh the bottom statistics from the
training data set you're going to be
Computing them on the fly at test time
using all of your examples
cool any questions on on how this works
yeah
so the question is how do we train the
initialization and the loss function at
the same time
um one really critical thing is that
we're only going to be training the
inner loss function and the outer loss
function is going to stay the same and
so uh if you if your interloop update is
something like Theta minus Alpha grad L
the parameters of L this neural network
is parametrized by Phi that takes as
input the unlabeled examples
um
I guess in this case there's only three
unlabeled examples
um
this is the inner loop update and then
we're going to be evaluating this uh in
terms of how well these updated
parameters do on
um
on the labeled examples which will be X1
to 3 and the corresponding labels and
this outer loss function will correspond
to just a standard cross-entropy loss
function and we could optimize this
entire thing
um
over both the initial parameters and the
the loss function parameters
cool any other questions
cool um so there's a lot of different
experiments in the paper but I'll
mention just a couple of them
um the first is the the Federated
extended feminist example that I showed
on the previous slide uh and in this
case the experiments are all trying to
adapt to new users that have different
handwriting only with unlabeled data
available at test time from those users
the experiments compare to a number of
different methods one of them is just
kind of standard ERM we can also compare
to the group robustness approach that I
mentioned before we can compare it to
domain adversarial training which was
covered in um
in in washu's lecture and also compared
to a really simple up waiting approach
that will just upweight the data from
each of the users to be a uniform
distribution so that you're sampling
data from them equally
um cool and then we can look at
performance both in terms of the average
test performance on these new users as
well as the performance on the worst
user and this sort of worst case
performance is useful because it will
give you a notion of fairness are you
doing really terribly on on some users
and much better on other users and also
gives you a notion of robustness such
that if your distribution changes more
towards those worst case users what will
your performance look like
if we look at the numbers first in terms
of average accuracy we see that domain
adversarial neural networks actually
gives you somewhat better performance
than than empirical Oris minimization
but that we can get around a five
percent Improvement by actually adapting
in this case with a context variable in
comparison to just trying to train a
single neural network
um then we in terms of worst case
accuracy we also see a round of five
percent Improvement as well
um over the best existing method
um in this case which corresponded to
either kind of up waiting or the domain
adversarial training
now we can actually kind of uh
qualitatively look at what it's doing
here and so here's one example where
this is an image that the system is
given and if you ask the neural network
trained with ERM it will tell you that
this is a two
um and similarly if you ask uh kind of
the the Adaptive risk motivation the
metal learned model that used a context
variable if we give it these two
examples and ask it what the
um what the label is it will also say
it's a two
but if you actually give it a little bit
like even more context if you give it
all of these unlabeled examples
it can correctly figure out that this
actually corresponds to a lowercase a
and the reason why I can do that is it
can look at other examples for example
this example and realize that this
particular user often writes their two
without a loop and therefore this must
be a lowercase a rather than the two
and so essentially what the system is
doing is it's adopting to this
particular user adapting the model to
the user such that it can more
accurately make predictions for that
user
cool
um what other experiment that I'll
mention uh was looking at adapting to
different image Corruptions and so this
is using the c4c and tidymage.c data
sets it was trained using 56 different
Corruptions and then testing using
testing's ability to adapt to images
that were corrupted with 22 other
Corruptions that weren't seen during
Trading
uh and again here we see
um
we see that the domain adversarial
neural network approach is one of the um
one of the best performing prior
approaches although
um it actually really is performing
somewhat similarly to just standard
empirical risk minimization
um and in contrast by actually adapting
and training for fast adaptation with
unlabeled data we're able to get around
a two to three percent Improvement
average accuracy and a seven to nine
percent Improvement in worse group
accuracy
yeah
it's because
19 Corruptions in C4 tendency so how
these links are created um when you say
like these drug captions are they like
still super kind of options
like imaginary patients like relations
is totally different from a corruption
it's like you need very different
distributions is it able to handle like
a very different kind of restrictionship
yeah that's a great question so
um first in terms of the Corruptions uh
we construct more Corruptions by also
considering the severity of the
corruption as well um and so I think
that's how we get to 78 Corruptions here
um and then in terms of being able to
handle very different
um Corruptions I I think that it it may
still help somewhat but
um
but I do think that like the
improvements will be less than the
improvements that you get from
Corruptions that are a little bit more
like the one seen during training
um and that's because we're still we're
training for adaptation performance on a
set of Corruptions and if you give it um
something it has to adapt to something
that's very different from that
um it won't necessarily generalize
[Music]
um we don't specifically have an
experiment that was looking at like how
performance does as
um as the severity changes my guess
would be that
um that it does help more when the
severity increases because ERM does much
better than these when there's no
um when there's no corruption and so uh
it and I don't think these methods would
help when there's no Corruption of
course um so my guess is that it would
be better with more severe Corruptions
but it's also possible that you might
see like a bit of a fall off if if it's
just too corrupted to be able to get any
signal
cool um so the takeaway here is that we
can use meta learning to adapt to
distribution shift and specifically to
adapt to
um different kinds of domains uh only
using unlabeled data
now
um what about other forms of
distribution shift
specifically next we'll look at a kind
of distribution shift that's called
concept drift or concept shift and this
is when
um
basically kind of the entire P of Y
given X distribution can change
um and actually I guess in a lot of the
examples that we'll be looking at P of X
is not going to be changing only P of Y
given X is going to be changing
um and I should note that when P of Y
given X is changing uh
you're going to need some sort of
supervision in order to adapt to the
distribution shift uh
because of because P of Y given X could
change in a lot of different kinds of
ways
um and specifically in this case we'll
look at uh
the handling this kind of distribution
shipped in the context of language
models
although a lot of the methods that we'll
be looking at are applicable Beyond
language models as well
and as a motivating example if you take
a version of dpt3 that was accessed
earlier this year
and you ask it what is the largest
English-speaking EU Nation
it will tell you the answer is the
United Kingdom but of course the UK is
no longer in the EU and so this answer
isn't correct and the answer should be
Ireland
um if you ask it who is ideal algeria's
current president I will also give you
an answer that is out of date
uh and likewise if you ask at the club
team that Leo Messi plays for
um it will give you
um something that's out of date as well
and so
there's a question of how like what
should we do in the scenario what should
we do to try to actually
update something like gpt3 in order to
allow it to make correct predictions
on things about the world that are
changing
uh unfortunately it would be really
expensive to have to retrain gpt3 or
even fine-tune gpt3 I would probably be
fairly expensive
and so what we'd like to be able to do
is try to figure out how to keep these
large bottles up to date without having
to
fine-tune or without having to
completely trade like retrain the entire
model
and so this is where kind of the
framework of editing uh can come in
um what would be really nice is if we
could take our base model
um if you ask it who is the prime
minister of the UK it'll tell you the
answer is Teresa may which was of course
uh correct before but that's also like
three prime ministers ago now
and uh
what would be really nice is if we could
take this example and tell it that the
answer should be Rishi sunak and pass
that to a model editor
and
then
um get an edited model that can give us
the correct answer
um including a correct answer to
rephrasings of the questions or other
things that are in scope like is Rishi
sunak the prime minister of the UK
um furthermore we don't just want it to
give us the correct answer for inputs
that are in scope
um we also want to be able to ask it
things that are out of scope and
unrelated like who does Messi play for
and still have it give us the correct
answer so we don't want to have it
affect things that are unrelated to the
edit
um and so specifically to try to scope
out this problem a little bit more
um maybe your edit example is who is the
prime minister of the UK uh our scope is
um is kind of this the space of inputs
that are related to
um related to that input and that would
include rephrasings of the question
and there are also examples that are out
of scope uh like why is the sky blue
um it's also worth mentioning that there
are some examples that are in scope and
out of scope that are going to be much
harder uh like where is Vichy not the PM
this is going to be in scope but it's
going to be a little bit further and
more difficult than just a rephrasing of
the question
and likewise there are things that
seemingly are somewhat related but
shouldn't be changed when we make an
edit to the model
um and these are actually really the the
most challenging cases and it's
important to um when we actually get to
some of the experiments we're actually
going to be trying to focus on
evaluating on these examples rather than
the easy examples like why is the sky
blue
yeah so what about prompts that aren't
in the form of the question so
um the
I guess
um so in principle yes the you could
have some of those things be in scope or
out of scope and you don't just have to
have this for a question answering model
um you could have it be for just general
language models um and if you have a
model that can do both question
answering and um kind of continuations
then you could have those kinds of
things be kind of part of this picture
as well
yeah
you
you have Theresa made it together
yeah so that would also be in scope as
well and you could also Imagine I mean
getting along the lines of like
um other other kinds of inputs you could
also have something like a picture of
Theresa May and say is this person the
Prime Minister and in principle that
would also be in scope as well
um if you're considering models that can
take that sort of input
cool
um so this is what we'd like to be able
to do
uh and
we can formulate this as a meta learning
problem
um and so there was this really cool
paper uh by citizen at all in 2020 that
uh kind of framed this problem as a meta
learning problem of trying to actually
train a neural network that could be
edited in very specific ways
um unfortunately
um and we'll talk about the kind of the
formulation from that paper
unfortunately this kind of specific
method in the iClear 2020 paper wasn't
particularly scalable to large language
models and so in terms of the methods
that we'll be covering
um we'll be covering some more recent
work that is much more scalable
um but this was the kind of the work
that introduced the the Paradigm of
doing this in the medal learning setting
and so to frame this as a metal learning
problem we are going to
assume that we have the ability to
collect a data set that shows us
examples of how editing should be done
and in particular this data set will
contain uh first a descriptor of the
edit this could be an input output pair
like who is the UK pm and the answer is
Rishi sunok
um it will also include an example of
something that's out of scope
um and this is going to try to enforce
the fact that the
um the model shouldn't change on these
out of scope examples
and it'll also include examples of
inscope uh in scope input output Pairs
and so in particular if it's given an
example like the Prime Minister the UK
is currently who um it'll be told like
what the the new answer to that question
should be
so this edit data set will essentially
be something that will will use to teach
a model editor how to edit a model
um collecting this edit data set is
going to be a non-trivial effort
although in general
um if we collect a general enough edit
data set that has examples of lots of
different kinds of things that we might
want to do to edit models then we only
need to train a single we only need to
use it once and collect it once
um in order to train a single model
editor for making all sorts of edits to
a large model
cool
um and then once we have that edit data
set there are a few different ways that
we could train one of these model
editors
the first approach is going to
try to actually change the the gradients
and actually update the weights of the
model
and so what it will do is it will take
his input the gradient that corresponds
to the gradient of trying to find two in
the model on that one edit example
and it'll try to transform that
fine-tuned ingredient into a better
update for the model
um and so this is kind of captured by
this picture where if you have your
pre-trained model and you want to make
an edit to it then you
compute what the gradient would be if
you were to fine tune on that edit
and then pass that gradient into this
model editor that will then give you an
updated gradient that you'll actually
use to edit the model
and once you apply this updated
um this kind of revised version of the
gradient to the model the goal will be
that it for it to
um for it to give you the correct answer
for uh for these edits and also of
course
um
not affect the model output on other
examples
and so really the main component of this
is just training this single model
editor right here in the middle
um it's going to take his input a
gradient and update a modified and
output and modified version of that
gradient
and the way that this is trained is
using the edit data set it will be
trained to Output the correct prediction
on the in-scope generalization example
and it will be told to that it should
kind of maintain the same distribution
of outputs given the out of scope
example as the original model
so there's two terms in the loss
function
yeah
that's a question so the question was
um isn't this more expensive than
fine-tuning because you're still
Computing the gradients
um so yeah you do need to still compute
the gradient
um the one big thing is that we're only
going to be applying One update to the
model
so we're going to be outputting a
modified gradient a modified gradient
such that just one step of that gradient
One update gives you a good model
and so it will require fewer update
steps than fine-tuning and second it's
also just going to work better than
fine-tuning uh and so the um by actually
training it to do this
um it will give you something that uh
kind of more effectively uh
makes targeted edits without affecting
out of scope examples
um so the question is what like is there
any sort of analysis on what's what is
doing to the gradient
um unfortunately it's a little bit
difficult to analyze I would guess that
it is it is probably kind of increasing
the scale to some degree uh but I'm it's
certainly doing more than that
um and generally it's hard to interpret
weights of neural networks and it's also
hard to interpret gradients so
um we weren't yeah we weren't really
sure how to analyze it in particular
um one thing that I will mention that
um
that we did in this work is that the um
the gradient of a single example uh is
actually a rank one Matrix so if you
have a weight Matrix and you compute the
gradient of that
um
so say you have a kind of one weight
Matrix right here
um this is like uh layer a and layer B
uh the gradient of this weight Matrix
corresponds to the outer product of
um of the forward activations so
uh well this isn't a great notation but
the forward activations and the um the
kind of gradient coming backward from B
so it's basically
um
something like dldb
um so this this is a vector this is a
vector and it's the outer product of
those two things and so it's actually a
rank one Matrix and
um one thing that's cool that this model
editor called mend does is it actually
decomposes instead of kind of passing in
the weight matrices it passes in the two
rank one components
um into the network and outputs a rank
one or a low rank update to the model
and as a result uh this ends up being
um
the dimensionality of the inputs and
outputs of this model editor are much
smaller and so in particular if you
um if this is like h a and HB are they
kind of the size of these two uh
activations then this weight Matrix is h
a times HB whereas the dimensionality of
the two rank one terms is H A Plus HB
and this means that the um
the kind of dimensionality of the input
is um
is going to be much much smaller than if
you were to Output input and output the
kind of
the entire weight Matrix
cool um so this is the first approach to
model editing that's actually to try to
update the weights or change the weights
of the model directly
um
before I go over some of the results I'm
also going to show a second approach to
model editing that tries not to update
the weights of the model and the
motivation for the second one is that
this approach ends up being
um somewhat difficult to scale to large
numbers of edits uh because it's
actually fairly fairly difficult to
figure out how to kind of change the
weights in a way that will make these
sorts of targeted edits
and so
um the second approach is going to try
to take a more semi-parametric approach
and so we'll have our base language
model and instead of updating the
weights of this language model it's
actually going to be fully Frozen
and instead we're going to try to form a
wrapper around that language model such
that the wrapped language model gives
you the behavior that you want after
you've applied the edits
and so this approach will have a few
different components
um the first will be a memory of edits
uh that stores all the edits that you
want to apply to the model
the second will be a scope classifier
that will classify whether or not an
edit and input are within scope
um this is actually going to be somewhat
similar to something like matching
networks or prototypical networks we're
actually going to be comparing the edits
that you want to make and the inputs and
seeing if they're similar or not
and then Additionally you can train a
counter factual model that will make
predictions
um if the edit is being applied to them
all and so the way this works uh at test
time is First you can populate the edit
memory with the edits that you want to
make to your model
uh the this is the one slide that I
didn't update with the correct PM
because the PM is changing rather
quickly
um the
um then when we get a new test input uh
what we're going to do is we're going to
first compare that test input to the
edits in our memory bank
the scope classifier will tell us that
this edit is in scope
and then because there is an edit in
scope we'll then pass the uh
the edit as well as the input to the
counterfactual model which will give us
the revised prediction for the input
alternatively if we get a example that's
out of scope
then we'll just pass that directly
autoscope for all the edits according to
the scope classifier then we'll just
pass that directly to the base model
uh and so really there's just two
components that we're training here
first is a scope classifier that will
tell us whether or not an example and an
edit are whether an example is in scope
for a given edit and then the second is
the counter factual model which we'll
train to make predictions
um after applying the edit for a given
example
yeah so one thing that you could do
instead of having a counter factual
model is essentially prepend the edit to
The Prompt of the base model and one
potential advantage that this might have
is that it will leverage kind of the
power of this really large base model
um
in practice we found that that didn't
seem to work that well
um
but perhaps you could fine-tune the base
model in order to be good at that sort
of
um that sort of prompted Behavior Uh and
the counterfactual model
um seemed to do seem to do reasonably
well
um but it's something that I do think
that kind of trying to leverage the base
model
um more I think would be kind of an
interesting direction for future work
yeah
foreign
yeah so the question is um is this
scalable especially as you want to apply
a large number of edits and do you need
the counterfactual model to be large so
um first yeah so this will
um as a number of edits increases you
will still need to store all of those
edits in memory fortunately you can
apply the scope classifier in parallel
to all of those edits and also in
practice for the edits we actually only
need to store the embeddings of the
edits we can just kind of cache that
computation so there is things that you
can do to make it computationally fairly
uh fairly cheap
um the other thing that you could do is
if you do start to accumulate a very
large number of edits at that point it
may but just make sense to fine-tune
your model
um because at that point you you do need
to actually change the model fairly
significantly
um and hopefully that
um you don't accumulate edits that fast
over time
and then in terms of the counter factual
model in practice we do kind of
pre-train it with like a bird style
model and so it it won't be necessarily
as large as the base model but it could
still be somewhat large and with that
sort of with like a bird style
pre-training we found that
um it can work well even with um
editing edit data sets that are like far
less in size than the um
then the data set trained that the
baseball was trained on
yeah
so with this type of contribution like
if we see something bad things within
the scope we kind of just completely
ignore the base model right
um is it possible to create something
that's kind of like
in which like instead of taking in the
instead of just sending it to a separate
kind of fraction model like the
contractual model just edits the output
of the base model I would like to
yeah so what's the suggestion that came
up before is we could possibly prepend
um the edit to the base model's prompt
alternatively you could
um kind of make a prediction from the
base model and then pass that into the
counter factual model and
um that might still be leveraging like
all the power of the space model and
then it would only be editing the output
um
of um of this base model and so I think
that for for things like question
answering
um that isn't necessarily that important
but I think that if you're in a setting
where like the task is to like write
long form text
um then something like that may actually
make a lot more sense because generating
long-form text is is much harder uh than
answering a question and also it may be
that you only need to edit a small part
of that long form text uh and so yeah I
think that generally different
directions for leveraging the base model
are interesting and and one way to do
that possibly maybe to kind of uh take
the output of the base model and pass
that into the counterfactual model
one of the small things that I'll
mention that's kind of a benefit of
having the 2B decoupled is that
um by having them be decoupled this does
mean that you could actually plug in any
base model into this architecture and we
we found experimentally that
um even if you kind of train this whole
system with one base model you can kind
of apply it to lots of different base
models and that means that even if you
then kind of retrain a base model at
some point you could kind of still reuse
the editor across multiple different
base models
cool
um so in terms of the experiments
um I'll highlight just two experiments
the first was on question answering just
like all the examples we've been looking
at so far
and
there were two metrics that we looked at
in order to evaluate how good the editor
was performing
the first was edit success which
corresponds to accuracy on in scope
examples
and then the second was drawdown which
corresponds to how much is the accuracy
dropping
on examples that are out of scope from
the edit
in order to combine these two things
into one metric we can just measure edit
success minus drawdown
and so the best that you could do is at
a success of one and a drawdown of zero
and so that then the subtracting the two
would give you one and then as this
score goes down that means that either
your edit success is dropping or your
drawdown is increasing
cool and then we're going to evaluate
this as we increase the number of edits
that we're going to be applying at test
time
and we'll be in this case editing a T5
large model on the type of question
answering things that we've been seeing
so far
um and so if we compare
um the three different editing
approaches I guess I didn't include
fine-tuning on here although fine-tuning
generally doesn't uh kind of does worse
than all three of these methods
um
first we see that with a single edit
um both mend and sarak are able to do
both both kind of the approach I was
editing the weights and the
semi-parametric approach are able to do
fairly well but as you increase the
number of edits
um
really these approaches that try to edit
the weights of the model are much less
successful at doing so and
um and really only sarak is able to
achieve a high edit success and a low
drawdown as you increase the number of
edits
cool and then um what other experiment
that I'll mention is um
you don't necessarily have to just edit
factual knowledge and and
um and so forth and so one experiment
that we did was editing the sentiment of
a um
of a model and so we trained it to edit
the sentiment on a variety of different
topics and then at test time if we ask
one of Facebook's prior public models
what do you think about vaccines it
gives you a model that is very negative
about vaccines so everything highlighted
in red is things that are negative
and then if you actually try to edit
this model with the the latter sarak
approach you can get something that is
in this case we're telling it to be more
positive and so as a result you see that
it's much more positive about vaccines
and it's not just positive in a
superficial way it also it says things
like I think they're a good way to
prevent infectious diseases
um I think it's good for people to be
informed about the risk of their health
and so forth
um and so the sort of editing approach
uh I think is actually fairly General
and as long as you have a data set that
can tell it
um how to how you want it to make edits
then you could apply it in a variety of
different ways
um to these very large models
cool um so the takeaways of this first
part is we can use metal learning to
enable adaptation and fine-tuning of
these large models either with only
unlabeled Target data or with a high
level description or single example of a
change that you want to make and these
are two things that are I think very
difficult to do just with vanilla
fine-tuning
cool
um now I also want to talk a little bit
about
um meta learning across more General
task distributions we're a little bit
low on time so I'm it's possible I might
just cover the first thing
um and and skip the second thing
this work is really about trying to kind
of push the boundaries of meta learning
and trying to see if we can get
something that's much more General than
the priors that we've been looking at
previously
uh and uh this is a paper that uh came
out on trying to train generic
optimizers
and it's a really cool paper
um and really the goal of their work was
to try to get an Optimizer that worked
well for any problem and any
architecture without having to tune the
kind of hyper parameters of that
Optimizer and so without having to tune
learning rates or without having to tune
like momentum or or anything else of the
optimizer
and
we'll get to the experiments at the end
but the the short version is is they
really
um they largely achieve this goal which
is I think is really exciting
um so it has four Central components um
the first is a neural network
architecture that predicts weight
updates
the second is a algorithm for training
that neural network
um the third is a very large and Broad
set of optimization tasks
and this is really important in order to
get the generic part of this
uh and then the last is a lot of compute
cool um so let's kind of Step through
each of those different components so
the first is the architecture
uh the architecture is actually somewhat
complicated but once you break it down
it's it's fairly simple so
first for every single weight uh for
every single parameter in the network
that you're optimizing there's a really
small uh neural network it's really a
tiny fully connected network with two
hidden layers they each have four units
and there's one of these fully connected
networks for every single uh for every
single parameter in your network
and this is the network that's going to
be outputting the parameter update for
that weight
now
um where do the weights of this network
come from so uh there's a separate
neural network that's an lstm that is
acting over the parameters in the weight
tensor
and this is going to be generating the
weights of all of the MLPs
for each of the parameters and so
um
this lstm so for every weight or I guess
for every tensor so like for every
weight Matrix for example you're going
to have an lstm that acts over those
weights
and that's going to be that LCM is going
to be outputting the um the kind of the
weight matrices of these really tiny
MLPs for all the parameters in that
tensor
um the input features to this lstm
correspond to a bunch of different
things it includes the mean and variance
of each of the parameter values in that
tensor a moving average of the gradient
and the squared gradient that's
information that atom uses uh also
things that indicate the fraction of
training that's been completed as well
so the input is um is all those
different features the output is the
weight matrices of this um of the small
MLP for each of the parameters
the last thing is this Global
aggregation
um the lstam is also going to Output a
global context uh This Global context
Vector is going to be pooled across the
weight tensors and then re-inputted to
each lstm
um and so this will just help the lsdms
basically stay on the same page
cool so that's the architecture
um
how do we actually train this
architecture uh so the meta objective is
the
the training loss at the end of the
optimization for each task
and so basically you'll have some
initial parameters for the task you'll
then use this architecture to update the
weights many times up until I think
around 200 000 steps
uh and then you'll get this final
parameter and the kind of the metal loss
will be how good is this final parameter
um
at the task that it is trying to do and
the objective will be this final loss
but of course average over all of the
different optimization tasks that's
being meta trained on
um
Now The Meta Optimizer is going to be
using Evolution strategies this is the
approach that you know covered in his
lecture
using full rollouts they're not going to
be doing any sort of truncation
and so this is going to be a pretty
expensive optimization so they'll take
this final loss and then update the
weights of the lstm
um
that are used to make all of these
different updates
then they also found a curriculum to be
extremely helpful and what they did is
they first started with optimization
problems with a smaller number of
training steps and with the smaller
problem size and then gradually move
towards longer training times and larger
problems
how do you measure problem size uh they
estimated the problem size this is just
the time required to do one forward pass
on the network and so this is an
indication of how big is the network or
how complicated is the network
cool
um and then lastly tasks in compute so
uh they constructed on the order of
millions of tasks uh with lots of
different architectures including MLPs
comdats Transformers rnns autoencoders
and also other learned optimizers
uh for each model family they vary the
training data set loss function
initialization strategy and various
hyper parameters like the hidden layer
size the depth the activation functions
and so forth
and they also did various forms of task
augmentations where they did things like
re-parametrizing the weight tensors
um for example like dividing the weight
tensor by a certain value passing that
into the having that be the weight
tensor and then having a constant B
multiplied after that delaying the
gradients changing the floating Point
precision and and other forms of task
augmentation
um and then computationally as we
mentioned on the previous slide we're
doing full rollouts uh and we are
um optimizing this with evolutionary
strategies and so they estimated that it
took around 4000 TPU months to uh
meditate the optimizer
which is rather uh expensive
so let's get to some of the results
um
their first evaluation was on a set of
83 canonical tasks and this is measured
in terms of the number of update steps
relative to required to get the same
performance as a version of atom where
they tuned the learning rate of atom
and so
um the red line shows this versatile
alert Optimizer or Velo
and first we can see that on on 50 of
the tasks fellow is more than four times
faster than the learning rate tuned atom
and on basically all of the tasks it is
actually the same speed or faster than
atom in terms of the number of update
steps
uh and they also compare
um not just to Adam but also these other
optimizers including optimizers for
which they tune the hyper parameters
um like Obelisk and shampoo and also
um
kind of a prior
um prior methods that are uh hyper
parameter free for which there didn't
need to be any tuning
um so this result in my mind is really
impressive uh and pretty exciting that
you could actually
uh on such a large number of tasks uh
outperform Adam
um what I think is even more interesting
and cool is actually looking at how well
it's able to optimize things are things
that were out of distribution
um so they looked at a lot of different
out of distribution tasks
um here they compared to a few different
methods although I generally tend to
focus on the comparison to Adam because
I think that's what um
people use the most uh at least in terms
of research
and they evaluated on Nerf training Nerf
is a very different kind of
um
I mean something's really different kind
of architecture but it's a very
different kind of optimization problem
than what it saw during training and we
can see that it is despite the fact that
this is an out of distribution task uh
or at least seemingly out of
distribution
um the optimizer is able to optimize
faster than atom so you can compare the
red curve and the blue curve and the
blue curve is actually a tuned version
of atom where they tried
um this is kind of the best out of 14
different hyper parameter settings of
atom
um they also looked at an MLP mixer
architecture which is um just a
different architecture than anything
that's seen during training and we also
see
um
improvements over atoms so red is is
faster than blue
um
they also looked at object detection uh
so this is uh this kind of rcnn
architecture as well as a decision
Transformer and you see that it's better
than SGD on object detection and
um and kind of similar to a decision
Transformer or similar to Adam on on
decision Transformer
cool um any questions about the results
yeah
[Music]
for the opportunity
um I'm not fully sure I would guess that
uh they chose to use SGD because that's
like the default architecture that's
used for this
um or the default Optimizer that's used
for this uh but I'm not fully sure
cool
um so they also had a really long list
of
um they also included a number of
experiments that it didn't work in
um although in general
um in general I felt like the results
were really kind of impressive
um the first caveat here is that is kind
of compute
um even though it's faster in terms of
the number of updates uh there is a 10x
computational overhead over atom
and so it's it's more expensive to run
the LCM compared to running atom
that said compute is often dominated
more by gradient computation than the
optimizer computation and so this may
not be that big of a deal you may still
get wall clock speed UPS
and second they had some experiments
that we're looking at the performance
with varying baptizes and you can see
that it actually does
um certainly does well
um with very large batches and this
means that if you're worried about wall
clock time you can get
um you can still get actually like a
much better wall clock time than atom by
just using a larger batch size
because this means that the when you
have a larger batch size your compute
will be even more dominated by the
gradient computation
um they also found that the model the
optimizer doesn't do well at optimizing
very large models
um specifically models that had more
than 500 million parameters and so if
you're in the business of training large
language models
um this may not be the optimizer for you
um they also found that it had worse
performance if you required more than
200 000 update steps uh because that
they because they only trained for up to
200 000 update steps
um and lastly they found that in
reinforcement learning settings
specifically policy gradient and
evolutionary strategy optimizations
um it was much worse than Adam uh this
isn't too surprising because it wasn't
trained on these kinds of tasks and the
gradients that you get from policy
gradient and Es on reinforcement
learning problems is going to be very
different than the gradients you
typically get from gradient descent
I guess maybe the other consideration
here is whether it's worth uh spending
uh
4 000 CPU months I think what was um on
on trading this sort of Optimizer uh
in principle if it kind of speeds up a
lot of future experiments uh by being a
single generic Optimizer then I think
that there is is probably a case for it
being being worth it but uh there's
always um it's always kind of I think
worth considering
um weighing computational costs and so
forth
cool um so the takeaway here is that met
alerting can produce uh generic
optimizers which is uh really in my mind
the kind of the first
um we've seen some results that have
moved towards more optimizers that
generalize well but we certainly haven't
seen something that's kind of truly
giving something generic uh
at this um at this level before
cool
um
we're a little bit low on time I think
I'll just briefly mention some of this
work
um
uh so that we still have time to go
through some of the um some of the open
challenges so
um the second kind of thing that I think
you can meddle learn over in addition to
the optimizer is the architecture
and um
and kind of the kind of symmetries that
are built into an architecture uh one
example of the symmetries built into an
architecture is convolutions which gives
you 2D equivariance
and
um things like convolutions are great
when we know the structure and we know
how to build it in but there are also
scenarios where we don't know what the
structure should be and we or we don't
know how to build it in
and so there's this question of whether
we might be able to use meta learning to
recover the equivariant or invariant
structure underlying a data set
um for example could you recover
convolutions if you're given
translationally equivariant data
um
the
you might ask if mammal can already do
this and mammal can learn some
equivariant initial features but that
equivariance may not be preserved
through the gradient update
and so really the goal here is to try to
decompose the weights into equivalent
structure and the corresponding
parameters such that
in the Inner Loop you can update only
the parameters and try to retain the
equivariance and keep that fixed
and so we can walk through an example of
convolutions where if you look at a 1D
convolution
[Music]
um
you get something like this and you can
actually represent a 1D convolution as a
fully connected layer and if you do that
it looks like this where the weights are
copied uh multiple times
and from this perspective you can think
about trying to re-parametrize this
weight Matrix into first the underlying
filter parameters a b and c
and second the a matrix that indicates
how the weights should be shared or how
the weights should be tied
and
um kind of the the product of the
sharing Matrix and the underlying filter
parameters will give you a weight Vector
that you could reshape into the
corresponding fully connected weight
Matrix
and you can kind of intuitively think of
the sharing Matrix as capturing the
symmetries and the uh the vector v is
capturing the underlying shared
parameters
now this was an example for convolutions
but it turns out that this sort of
decomposition can directly represent
um
this decoupled equivariant sharing
pattern and filter parameters for a wide
range of symmetries specifically for all
kind of G convolutions with for finite
Group G
um there are some symmetries that this
can't represent but we won't have time
to get into that here
cool um and so once you have this
decomposition of the weight Matrix you
can basically in the outer loop learn
the aqua variants and possibly the
initial parameters and then the inner
loop only update the parameters while
keeping that sharing Matrix fixed
um and so
uh if you if you do this
um you can try to actually see if you
can recover things like convolutions
from translationally equivariate data
and so specifically here we're going to
try to recover 1D convolutions
by giving it examples of random
um random functions that have this 1D
translation equivariants
uh and if you do this
um this is of course this is kind of
showing the mean squared error on these
random tasks on random held out tasks
and
um this is if you do mammal with a fully
connected network with a locally
connected Network or with convolutions
and of course convolutions does the best
because that reflects the underlying
symmetry of the tasks
um and if you use this approach with a
fully connected Network it's actually
able to do just as well as convolutions
because it's able to recover the
structure
and so specifically if you look at the
recovered weight Matrix
um from this sort of approach where it's
meta learning the sharing Matrix
uh you see that it actually gives you
exactly
um the structure of a 1D convolution
cool and then there's a question of well
maybe you could also do better than
convolutions in scenarios where the
structure isn't exactly translationally
translational Aqua variants and so you
can give it problems that have partial
translation symmetry so here
um K is going to correspond to the rank
of a locally connected net layer and so
k equals one corresponds exactly to
convolutions where k equals 2 and k
equals three
um has less Symmetry and here we see
that uh the the sort of approach is able
to recover a solution that's much better
than convolutions by actually recovering
something closer to the two true
structure in the data
um and likewise you can try to actually
give it more symmetries than just
translation like rotation and reflection
um here we actually started with a
convolutional network and tried to learn
symmetry on top of that and you can get
again something that's better than
convolutions um by recovering that sort
of structure
um these are all on fairly simple
problems
um but I think that it still uh kind of
conceptually pretty cool to think about
how you might try to metal learn these
kinds of
um
these kinds of architectures from data
and um
the um maybe if you were able to kind of
maybe if you did scale up these kinds of
approaches uh with um with more compute
then we might be able to actually do
this at a much larger scale rather than
these kind of simple 1D convolution
problems
cool um so the takeaways is that we we
saw how metal learning can produce a
generic Optimizer and we saw some
preliminary evidence of metal learning
being able to capture
um equivariances in neural network
architectures
open challenges
so
um
I'll group these into a few different
categories so the first category I think
of open challenges is trying to address
some of the problem assumptions that we
um that we often make in in meta
learning problems and multitask learning
problems
and the first is uh is generalization so
this actually kind of came up earlier
when we were talking about trying to
generalize to Corruptions that are very
different from the Corruptions that we
saw during training
um and one specific instantiation of
this is like a long-tailed problem where
you want to try to be able to generalize
to the tail of the distribution
in this case uh the infused learning in
principle we should be able to kind of
meditate on this part of the
distribution and then do a few shot
learning on the tail of the distribution
um but these few shot tasks and the tale
of the distribution may be from a
different distribution than the task
that we saw during meta training
and so there are some examples of
generalization to the Tails of
distributions and
um
in like Dermatological diseases and also
kind of the Adaptive risk minimization
example we saw before
um but it's still I think an open
challenge to really kind of truly tackle
these kinds of long-tailed situations
and I think that there may be perhaps
some hints that kind of come from some
of the robustness literature and perhaps
trying to combine
um those sorts of ideas with um with
things like meta learning
um another thing that's uh
another challenge that comes up is so
far we've really been looking at meta
training
um over tasks that are from a single
modality
and
um in contrast when people leverage
previous experience uh we have not just
one modality of data but we have lots of
modalities like
um tactile feedback and language and
social cues and we're able to merge all
of that prior experience into
um into the knowledge that we have and
leverage for example cues from language
that we've read about when making visual
decisions and so forth
and so
um I think it'd be really interesting to
try to learn priors across multiple
different data modalities rather than
trying to learn a prior that works well
for a single modality and there's some
challenges and opportunities here uh
different modalities often have
different dimensionalities or different
units uh
but they can also carry kind of
complementary forms of information and
that might be quite useful uh when
trying to actually leverage that prior
information
um there's some kind of I think initial
Works in this direction including the
flamingo paper that Eric covered in his
lecture
um also the gato paper that tried to
train a single agent on lots of
different modalities
but I think that there's still still
like a really a long way to go in terms
of trying to capture all of this Rich
prior uh information when learning new
tasks
um and then lastly uh Beyond
generalization and multimodality uh one
question that I think has come up quite
a bit in this course is actually trying
to understand when multitask learning
might help versus when you might just be
better off trying to learn a specialized
model uh and so there's all sorts of
questions around algorithm selection and
model selection that I think are still
fairly wide open to explore in future
work
um Beyond building better algorithms I
think that also a big part of uh of
research and a big part of that of a
research that feels progress in machine
learning AI is better benchmarks and I
think that we need benchmarks that
challenge current algorithms to find
common structure and arguably
um
they kind of learn to optimize our work
that we just talked about was fueled by
a lot of compute of course but also a
benchmark that had a much broader set of
optimization tasks than um than was
previously considered
uh and we also want benchmarks that
reflect real world problems that um that
will have an impact on the world
and so we've seen um kind of some steps
towards some good benchmarks uh over the
past few years uh in in various domains
uh although I think that there's still
really a lot of progress that can be
done here uh and I especially think that
a lot of benchmarks primarily look at
computer vision or NLP domains and
there's all sorts of domains outside of
images and text uh that are that are
extremely useful and impactful including
things like satellite imagery or
molecules and I think we often don't see
benchmarks that do a good job of
covering those kinds of problems as well
foreign
and then lastly beyond the uh kind of
addressing problem assumptions and
benchmarks is also just trying to
improve the core algorithms uh we saw in
the Learned Optimizer work that by level
optimization can be very expensive uh
and so perhaps there are ways to
actually make that cheaper
and approaches both in terms of reducing
computation reducing memory that um
make it possible to do things like that
with much less compute
uh and also I think that there's
um always a lot of room to develop about
our theoretical understanding of these
different kinds of approaches which may
also eventually then
um kind of fuel advances in the
algorithms themselves as well
um and then beyond these also
um I'm sure that you found challenges in
your own homeworks and um and final
project and so this list certainly isn't
complete uh it's just some of the things
that I think are are particularly
interesting directions for future
investigation
um and then lastly I'd like to end on a
slightly kind of bigger picture view uh
which is that I think that the um I
think that still if you think about some
of the biggest uh Milestones or at least
what a lot of people think of as the
biggest milestones in AI research uh you
think of things like IBM Watson or
um like the alphago system that was able
to kind of uh be kind of a champion in
alphago or in go
um and all these systems are really
specialized for one particular
application or game or problem uh and
even things like gpg3 are really I think
pushing the boundaries in terms of
generality but they're still specialized
to this domain of text
uh and in contrast we
um we know that humans are uh are much
more General they they don't limit limit
themselves language they don't limit
themselves to playing the game of Go
um from day one and so
uh I think that the um yeah we still
have I think a long way to go in terms
of the field of artificial intelligence
of moving towards things that are more
General and um have broader Notions of
intelligence uh and in this course we've
covered I think a few different things
that are I think steps towards building
more General systems like learning uh
multiple tasks in a single model
leveraging previous experience when
learning new things leveraging unlabeled
prior data uh or data from different
domains
um as well as trying to learn
continuously over time rather than just
trying to learn
um one thing
and so
um
there's of course I think bits and
pieces that are that are still missing
towards uh
towards getting artificial intelligence
that can uh operate at the same level
that humans can but I think that
hopefully through this course you're
much better equipped at trying to
understand what might be missing uh for
building these kinds of systems
cool
um that's it uh I'd like to thank all of
you for a really awesome quarter uh but
thank you everyone for being so engaged
in the lectures and um yeah for a great
quarter